hello to all our friends and family in
the UK from cat Claire
and Amy have a very Merry Christmas and
a Happy New Year from the female mentors
here at Google
I'd like to wish my musing waveclear I'm
a to amazing children
Abby and Emily and amazing Christmas and
a Happy New Year I'd also like to wish
my mom and my two sisters
my dad an island and amazing Christmas
and Happy New Year and all of youse all
it's what a bunch of friends are far
from family happy Christmas and a Happy
New Year missing your loads will be
almost soon as we can
you have a good one Merry Christmas pips
hi mom and dad its Anthony here in Kabul
I just want to say hi and happy
Christmas sorry I can't be home to be
with you but I hope you having a great
day and also to Mel Teresa Jenny happy
Christmas to you guys too and of course
my beautiful girlfriend Steph I'll be
home to you soon take care
all right over here just wishing my mom
my dad's sisters brother-in-law and
girlfriend Susie a happy Christmas from
sunny kabul hope is not really on you
too much back at all keep safe hi this
is sally in new kabul compound just want
to wish my mum Pete Chui a very Merry
Christmas and all my orienteering
friends back out in the UK hello
everyone and season's greetings from
Kabul city
I just like to wish all my friends and
family across the world are very Merry
Christmas and an excellent 2016 god
bless you all thank you